hey everyone welcome we are now sitting
down with Kathy pearl hello thanks for
joining us my pleasure appreciate it so
we will be talking about conversational
interfaces so this is your heading the
design and outreach is that right ahead
of conversation design outreach Google
that Google okay and then I want to talk
to you about so many things there's like
the technical side of things but then
there's like the evolution of how it's
evolved maybe we dabble into the
evolution first so it lets us do
evolution and technical at the same time
so it may be it's like how did this even
start these conversational interfaces
and then also like like as we've started
it we figured out how it works and we've
been tweaking it over time to make it
better sure well I mean back in the
1950s when artificial intelligence was
kind of first emerging as a thing it was
interesting because a lot of the
researchers thought oh language that'll
not that won't be too hard I mean
toddlers can speak we're gonna go after
the really hard stuff like chess that's
gonna be tough when in fact they
discovered very quickly that it's kind
of been the reverse things like chess
that are very rule-based computers could
do pretty well at but language has been
a real challenge for the computer
science community so it wasn't until
sort of the 1990s that voice even became
a thing that anyone sort of in general
out there in the world even knew about
which you would encounter when you
called your bank or your airline and you
would get a computer talking to you so
that's kind of where I started in the
late 90s was working on those IV r's
those phone systems but it's really
evolved since then the technology has
improved greatly and it's become more
mainstream instead of a barrier where
you call a service and you are forced to
speak to a computer now a lot of us
choose to speak to a computer because it
can be a helpful thing okay so we went
from it being more forced as in we would
call in for help right and then we would
get a kind of like a numerical press
this button for this that was the sort
of precursor and then it
to you know sort of menu items like you
can do this this or this what you're
calling about exactly and so that was
kind of evolution within the IVR space
an IVR mean sorry IVR means inner
interactive voice response interactive
voice response right okay and I I've
yours have a reputation of everyone sort
of really not liking them but they were
also have been and still continue to be
a lot of successful ones one of the ones
I'm most proud of I worked on called
5-1-1 where free prior to smartphones if
you're out in your car you had no way of
getting like traffic information or
transit information but I designed a
system where you could call in and get
the latest traffic and things like that
and it's still in the Bay Area still
gets you know millions of calls so there
were systems that people did like to
call and they did want to talk to mm-hmm
but there were a lot of bad ones out
there too so it was kind of a mixed bag
yeah it's the comparison between just
looking at Google Maps for traffic
versus calling you in a 5-1 baby talking
to somebody right okay and this would be
the interface that we engage with when
we do this is almost always non-human if
you're taught if you're calling one of
these systems yeah right you would be
speaking to in the case of IVRS it's
almost always pre-recorded human speech
so a voice actor goes into a recording
booth and records hundreds or thousands
of prompts we call them Wow
holy cow okay so that's how happens
voice actor goes in female or male
different languages and then they record
hundreds of thousands of prompts that's
how it used to be because what we call
computer speech text to speech or TTS
wasn't good enough back then to do
nowadays with things like Google home
you use text-to-speech
computer-generated voices because they
sound good enough that we can accomplish
things with them do some good enough
yeah and that's when we do something
like
do okay Google how old is Melinda Gates
there is 53 years old so that's it
coming back and using text-to-speech
right so so I mean and this is maybe
where we can get a little bit technical
about it but it's listening to what I'm
saying and putting that into text and
then running that text search and then
the text search brings back a result of
53 years and then and then that 53 years
is voiced back ass right has voice yeah
yeah and so then how is this some is the
this is technically very similar to the
process of voice chat as well when I'm
doing conversational interface with with
a program right so essentially you as
you described it first thing you have to
do is capture the sounds that are coming
out of the person's mouth what words are
those but at that point you don't really
have meaning you just know they said you
know the Cat in the Hat but you have no
idea what that means it's as if I was
transcribing a foreign speaker that I
don't speak their language I could
probably write down some sounds that
were what they said but I have no idea
what they mean so part two is you take
those words that have been you know as
you said transcribed and then you have
to extract meaning or intent what does
the user want here do they want to ask a
question like how old is Melinda Gates
do they want to set a timer do they want
to have an actual back and forth
conversation so they have different
needs and different intents depending on
what they say mm-hmm the intent because
question versus an action right could be
an action could be I just want to I just
watch that there's one shot yeah so it
could be different things so then could
I could I say something like okay Google
how are you feeling I'm doing great
thanks for asking I'm feeling sad it may
not be much but let me know if there is
anything I can do for you
cheer me up
okay Google cheer me up I love to
entertain we can write a mad lib story I
can find you a fun fact or you can spin
the wheel okay so we're kind of there a
little bit I mean that's pretty it's
pretty good for a bunch of one of the
most well-established and expensive and
companies in the world yeah start yes
and now the conversational interfaces
that are being built at Google this is
Google assistant where we just use now
is that part of the focus of the work
part of what I'm doing yes Google's and
the outreach like to when you get other
people excited about getting involved
what are the conversational interfaces
that are yeah being tough the outreach
yeah it's about sort of helping people
understand what conversation design is
so when we people often get these fun
ideas to create for example actions on
Google which is third parties can create
their own interactions with the Google
assistant but a lot of times they just
dive into the technical problem or the
the cool thing they're doing but they
don't really think about design so much
and what that ends up sometimes
happening then is you have a poor
experience with your user and your user
is frustrated doesn't want to use your
action that you created so part of my
mission is to educate people and help
them learn about this thing called
conversation design which is basically
like think about the old days of web
design where you saw a lot of bad
websites with like flashing lights and
they were hard to navigate and we've
kind of realized that to make a really
good website you need someone who knows
about website design similarly if you
want to have a great conversation with
whatever you're building you need to
apply design principles to it to be
really successful so when you're
teaching conversation design to new
people what are some of those principles
so some of the basic ones include it's
really important with the stage we're at
to let the user know when is it their
turn to talk and what can they
say or not say with a human we can talk
about anything we want we can probably
get back on track if you know if I say
something you understand you can always
follow up etc with these voice
assistants were more in the infancy and
so if you say like how can I help you
but in fact all you can do is book movie
tickets well that's a very off-putting
experience for these or because they're
gonna think oh I can ask anything when
really all you can do is buy movie
tickets just be very straightforward
about letting your user know this is
what I can do here's what you know let's
talk about those things the other part
is something we call air handling which
means when things go off track because
they often will go off track you have to
be able to get the user back on track
and so we emphasize don't just think
about the Hat what we call a happy path
where everything's going great think
about the times when maybe it didn't
understand the user or it made a mistake
how do we get the user to get back to
what they want to do so you have to
spend time on that the context makes a
lot of sense setting the context this is
what I can do this is what I can write
set the expectations very clearly
because we yeah we sometimes over set
them and people get frustrated because
they think well why can't you do that
mm-hmm yeah that seems to be huge and
then the that I have that's huge in
human community yes yes and then the the
second one remind me again with error
handling with air hit error handling
okay error handling so this is when the
conversation goes off track a little how
do you bring it back right so if you are
doing your movie ticket thing and you
say how can I help you and the user says
well what's a good pizza place now you
don't know anything about pizza places
so rather than just say I don't
understand how can I help you which
would be pretty useless because the user
is still stuck let me connect you to the
chat it'll say or say sorry I don't do
restaurant recommendations would you
like you know I can help you book movie
tickets is there a movie you're
interested yeah get back to the point of
things yeah error handle as and you read
out that it's a restaurant inquiry and
then you say can't do that if you can
you don't always know if they say you
know zebra zebra zebra you
any idea what they said so I might be
stroked animals we might not be able to
go that far but you might say sorry I
didn't quite get that but I can help you
book a movie is there a movie you'd like
me to look at something like that okay
so what are some of the futures that
were that we're experiencing I mean we
already have you know Google assistance
right here it's also Google home it's
also Amazon Alexa there's so many of
these so where we are we going to a
place where we are conversing with this
kind of like the movie her I get asked
that a lot and we are light years away
from that maybe that is the future but
then by light years I mean like 15 years
oh no I don't well this is my own
personal opinion is that 15 we're not
gonna be there 15 years and a lot of
that is because you think about what one
thing computers really struggle with
this common sense so something if I had
a real assistant they would know what I
meant if I said something that was out
of the topic we were discussing and
right now computers just are really not
great at building sort of a model of
what the real world is like and so as
soon as you go off track a little bit
from the topic they can struggle so I do
think we will be speaking and typing -
more and more of our devices and getting
more things done that way and having an
assistant do things on our behalf but
we're a long way from getting to the
kind where you can just chat about
anything at all and they can and they
could handle that the bandwidth is so
limited with fingers feels like the
bandwidth is much better with text or
what talking and then for even further
with video yeah for sure and I think
that to me that's one of the things I
love most about voice is that you don't
have to think about how am I gonna you
just speak naturally and if we do a good
job building our product then we can
understand your intent because people
ask for things the same thing in many
different ways even something simple
like I want to set an alarm for 8:00
a.m. there's 50 different ways I might
say set set a set an alarm for 8:00 I
want an alarm in the morning can you set
it for 8:00 a.m. I want a timer for 8:00
a.m. it's not even
timer to alarming yet that's what I
meant so you have to that's the thing
that's tricky about voice is people say
things the same thing a huge variety of
ways and we need to understand all those
different things because you parse the
word timer out of that and you're like
oh they want a timer but then it says
four eight yeah if you're a bad system
you'd say you know does not compute it
makes no sense if you're a good system
really well they really mean an alarm
I'll just you know that's what a human
would do human would say I know what
you're talking about you guys yeah so
how do we get conversational interfaces
to the point where it's more like humans
knowing what each other are talking
about even when the nuance and what's
being communicated is a little bit kind
of like the efficiency is not so direct
the efficiencies a little bit like you
said timer for 8:00 a.m. they mean an
alarm okay how about a question about
the what what are what are kind of the
other extent I mean you you were talking
about conversational interfaces will be
more so around us so we're talking like
the smart home things smart fridge smart
light Smart Oven Smart TV blah blah so
um you know set my mood for happy set my
mood for dinner
mm-hmm you know etc where else do you do
you see kind of us and drink right now
with the conversational interfaces like
where else are they going to be in the
car while we're driving sure that'd be a
great place because right now you know
if I want to I want to be able to switch
songs or switch podcasts or you know
make a phone call whatever and I want to
be able deal with my voice so I can be
completely hands-free so the car is a
great place for voice yep but really I
mean in the future it could be anywhere
you could just be outside on a hike and
take a picture of a tree and say what
what kind of tree is that and just use
your voice to do you know start that
task mmm and then image search and then
I would take care of right take care of
it
cool so it's oh so then it becomes a
intertwining of the different text acts
that we've built out because then we're
intertwining the the the voice-to-text
with the image search right it's just
it's just the way in to I mean the way
in right all the other few but then
those text acts have to be connected as
well right so that's a lot yeah exactly
so I think sometimes people may not
realize that the difficulty is not
always just in extracting the meaning
from the words that we recognize the
difficulty is then and you know you have
all these different api's all these
different layers where you've got all
these different systems that have to be
able to talk to each other in order to
carry out whatever your task is whether
that's making you know looking up a
recipe and sending the ingredients to
your shopping assistant or whatever you
know there's so many different aspects
to it and so it's a lot of that
underlying stuff that has to get to work
together yeah we pride ourselves a lot
on being very Polymathic like
multidisciplinary and so when when
you're when you weren't mentioning that
I was totally thinking about all the
ways that we got to make the connections
across the different stacks in order for
them what I'm able to communicate
together right to be useful to be really
useful yeah yeah hmm what where does um
I guess what are some of the insights
from natural language processing because
you were talking about the alarm versus
timer
what are some other insights that you
could share with us well one thing is
that people it's not just say phrases or
words like I might say pancakes you
might say flapjacks okay that's a pretty
straightforward example of one word
meaning the same thing but the tomato
tomahto yeah but people just have
different narratives I mean if I'm just
ordering pizza it's my pizza I'm telling
you my story and I might not do it the
same way as you so one person might say
I want three large pepperonis
to go and one other person might say I
want order some pizza so your
conversational system can't just be like
oh I'm expecting them to say the size of
the pizza at this stage well they might
they might not so they're gonna talk
about pizza but how they do it in what
order and the way they talk about it
can be different so even something that
seems super simple like ordering a pizza
ends up being slightly more a lot more
complex just because people are gonna do
it the way people are going to do it
okay so let's see if we can break this
down so it would be like let's let's
just say that the that we knew that
pizza was now gonna be ordered okay so
we are because we've seen the word pizza
order I want pizza order B to give me
some pizza that's like kind of the first
step now you know pizza okay great
now if they add three large pepperonis
if they said then the first one then you
could drop basically down a couple
layers and then you would already know
what they want so then you don't need to
ask what do you want right because
imagine a human if I say I want three
large I want a pizza and I want three
large pepperonis and you're like what
size would you like and you're like what
I just said no so we don't our computers
have to be able to do that so then
you're dropping down those those levels
so you can the efficiency in in in human
input when human goes in and speaks what
they want the more the more
characteristics of the item that they
desire that they describe off the top
like if you say I want to order from
this three large dislocation three large
pepperoni pizzas delivered at 6:00 p.m.
tomorrow use my business card right then
it's like whoa then you went 12 layers
and the transactions done basically and
people change that they correct
themselves I said I want to order three
pizza oh you're not coming oh I want to
order two pizzas I just had a
conversation with somebody else this is
a computer know that I was talking about
with common sense computers right now
don't always realize I'm actually
talking to somebody else they're they're
still listening to me and so they get
confused so you have to be able to
anticipate all these varieties and the
way we talk whoa yeah I love how complex
and interesting this is yeah because
it's
a massive human we evolved with language
it's but one of the most important
aspects of like helps us relate to each
other relate to things and and so I mean
that's just a major part of human
evolution so now to be able to put
programming and algorithms and
facilitating life processes with with
with conversational interfaces it's so
so cool so cool I'm really happy that we
unpacked those those layers actually
Google assistant had that the demo was
booking haircuts mmm right he was
booking haircut so it was like book me a
haircut between 12:00 and 2:00 p.m. on
the 15th and then and then that would be
the whole task it would be done it would
be given and you know either you would
have it would have a registry of where
you had you know went in the past or you
could recommend the exact salon or maybe
would ask you which salon of these three
do you want to go to but just like that
then the the this is maybe maybe we ask
you a quick about this so now the Google
assistant is making the phone call to
the salon now was that a hundred
thousand hours or a hundred thousand
phrases that were made by voice actors
or is that then being able to string the
different pieces of information together
that's just in this now massive database
of words that like the dictionary of
words that you can just string together
and it sounds like a for Google duplex
stuff I can refer you to the blog post
that that Google put out that talks a
little more about how about so Google
duplex yeah but that is what part of the
conversational interface right that's
part of the yeah now in terms of
outreach maybe let's let's definitely
touch on this so we're at women and tech
international we're here at the summit
and it's really important to get you
know to see people like you in these
roles because then we can inspire other
women and other
women to to get more involved is that
you you know you they see it they can be
it so what are what are you currently up
to with outreach and yet tell us about
that yeah as I said before my main
mission is to go out there and talk to
people about what is conversation design
why is it important when you should
think about it in your projects you know
what does it even mean what are the
principles and really get people excited
about the design portion and not just
not just the cool tech because the tech
is very cool but also to think about the
best way to go about is that you'll have
the best possible experience for people
and they'll want to use it and so
besides like the maybe like the
corporate clients and the colleges and
other startups and projects like that
for when they would want to use it
what about kind of like steam education
in in general is there like a tie to to
young women in in high school and so
Google definitely does sponsor some some
different organizations and I myself in
the past before I joined Google was a
volunteer for girls who code which is a
high school and junior high initiative
where are we going and help girls learn
to code but also just get excited about
coding and feel comfortable with that
one of the things I always like to tell
the girls in those classes is you know
maybe this will inspire you to become a
programmer maybe it won't it doesn't
have to but knowing how to program can
be a great asset no matter what role you
take even if you do something that's
totally different understanding the
underpinnings really helps you talk to
when you have to be talking to the
engineers about developing your ideas if
you have an understanding a basic
understanding of what that means it's
really really helpful get you get you
further in the game but also sometimes
you can write your own code to get stuff
that you might want like let's say
you're running a project let's say
you're doing a biology you're at a
biotech company and you're running
experiments and you want to get access
to the data for the experiment if you
have to go through an engineer they
might not have time that might not be
of what they're supposed to be doing if
you know enough coding to go grab some
data run some SQL queries get the things
you want you can just go get your own
stuff and start you know making your own
conclusions and things like that so it's
just super powerful even if you're not
going to become you know full-time coder
having a bit of background can just
really help you I have a very I know
like point zero zero one percent about
all this but what I can tell you is I
can at least have a kind of 10,000 foot
view of it and that helps me kind of
break down like that you know that pizza
example you know and so even that bare
minimum view of how it works can kind of
get you by yeah and then there's that
and then there's also the like you said
just be able to know the pieces like if
you apply the Pareto principle to code
maybe you learn the 20% of coding skills
that give you access to 80% of knowing
how to code certain things that you that
you need to do okay so you you authored
a book as well yes in 2016 it's called
designing voice user interfaces from
O'Reilly and it's a really great
introduction to anyone whether you're a
designer developer a project manager
product manager if you want to
understand more about this space what
does it even mean to build one of these
things what are the challenges including
the question should I build a voice user
interface for what I'm doing cuz voice
is not always I love voice but it's not
always the right technical solution for
the problem you're trying to solve so
the book will help you make that
decision and then give you guidelines
about how to actually go about doing it
and we'll have the link in the bio for
you guys to check out let's a couple
quick rapid-fire questions what he
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world oh my gosh there's so many things
to answer to that I guess I would put
two things in that one is just nature
the universe going outside and looking
at beautiful things out there and the
other one I think is just stories from
other people you know you cannot know
somebody they can live thousands of
miles away and you can see a really well
done video about them and it can meet
we move you and touch you and I think
that's phenomenal
yeah those are great
do you think we're alone in the cosmos
huh oh boy it seems hard to believe we
would be but then you also think well
why wouldn't we know by now but then
again the universe is huge so maybe he
just hasn't happened yet
so I'd like to think we're not alone mmm
yeah there's some fellow civilizations
out there I hope so yeah hopefully
they're friendly yeah yeah yeah and then
do you think we're in a simulation I
don't I think when I was in high school
I contemplated that and no I don't I
just think the odds against that are
just what I think nature and evolution
is too a bit too random and explains
everything that's going on right now we
don't need to come up with the
simulation theory to kind of explain
things of who we are that's exactly what
the simulator who I should that's true
there did the notes case kudos to them
they're doing a great job Kathy we only
started unpacking but I really
appreciate your time and this has been
super fun the Saints to sit down
together and get into conversational
interfaces I think we learned a lot even
just from the short amount of time
together thank you so much
thanks for coming onto the show and
everyone if you guys had a good time
make sure to give us a subscribe make
sure to comment below your thoughts
share the concerts other people get into
conversation with other people go and
create with this so going maybe get the
book go and start something yourself
maybe it's right for you to make one of
these also write about it make videos
about it go and create with the content
if you guys want us to continue coming
to cool places like the Women in
Technology summit
join us on patreon so we can continue
coming around and doing these interviews
with brilliant people around the world
especially women especially young women
so let's make it happen
join us thanks for watching and 50 soon
you